let's see if it works it says um life
but I really help it does one sound
because you know reason some 27th delay
yeah I'm okay you're young you are only
right now okay cool thanks 17 17 okay
yes your honor I will gotta hang up
skype okay okay okay cool okay guys
sorry for that that was not do we
happened but we have some twitches to
just kind of tricky sometimes but now we
are on let me get things sorted here
that was this technical support guy but
we are online um well I actually had
ruining head started a game this is by
the way the exact reason why I'm usually
doing those kind of em I live questions
at the beginning because sometimes the
software tells me I'm life and I'm not
and this was again the thing and very
very tricky sometimes so let's get going
going to play some games actually have
played one game um because I started it
right when the history was supposed to
be live and I won that game actually you
still see the rest of it okay there's
someone saying please answer more
questions today yeah giving my best
actually answer quite a lot the other
requests for chess variant tonight like
nine sixty suicide atomic yeah 960 I'm
I'm game but not the other one simply
because I don't know how they work yeah
I'm can press the 960 button hoping that
I get a game it's not so easy so let's
see yeah
okay there's a question someone is
asking let let me play a couple of moves
there someone is asking that some are
stating that some commentators are
overestimating or kind of pointing to a
couple of things when they do commentary
like the bishop pair more space those
kind of things and the question is it
says there are a lot of positions where
those things don't guarantee an
advantage um and how to determine that
it's not easy very difficult very
difficult questions however in most
positions some more space and the bishop
Pam is something actually quite a lot
and yeah I actually most of my Queens
are from space and bishop s so on I know
what I'm talking about um gasps speaking
of space this guy has much more space
he's playing a very sophisticated
version here of them sameish Kings
Indian a very tricky for black to handle
variation here okay let's see I'm going
for this classic f5 f5 thing I'm someone
asks me about the opening d4 d5 c4 c5
the Austrian defense to the Queens
gambit it's not very good
um yeah that's a good question um I
value the bishop pair highly yeah why
did I why did I then go for the nympho
Indian and and bogo Indian for my book
choice and my repertoire well they're
just good openings and it's not that
mean I do like the bishop am but it's
simply that every good player likes it
if the position is right for it and
especially the the NIMS o is so flexible
that giving up the bishop has no issue
at all talking about flexibility how am
I going to trap this bloody Queen down
he has put the Queen there on each six I
wonder if I can't rapid knight to e to g
eight it's totally I know is his founder
he found a way back there had to have to
it ok I'm still putting up this g5 stuff
ok yeah I am it that's not a big problem
him c5 and the capture um yeah still
about this question with the space and
the bishop here I don't think that those
commentators are automatically I'm
valuing this too high or something um it
just it just how it is
of course there are openings that don't
necessarily have space and and bishop
pair but it's still a very important
very important point um okay um do I
follow the Grand Prix no I don't yet
yeah I'm interested in this event of
course but I did not yet follow it
because I was a about was on the only
short vacation of about four days and
during that vacation I was unable or not
a table I didn't really watch anything I
only saw that the event started and
caruana its leading I think but I didn't
really look at it in much detail okay so
what is this mmm I need to make sure
that I have some share of the C file
here might nights are problematic here
that's not not such a great position if
5 is hanging okay
yeah that's not too great I know
okay I need some counter play him going
for the captcha and Bishop and and Queen
83 if possible yeah so I'm taking here
so v6 is hanging but I don't think that
I cannot worry about that let's put it
like that if he takes be 6 i'm going to
a 3 and try for this play there okay
just takes it immediately basically
saying what you're doing is rubbish
that's probably that's possible it
really is but I still think I have some
kind of player 96 was interesting but
he's playing instant moves all the time
so didn't happen Queen can take c5 okay
I can still check him for night age form
i go to h5 he has quincy form ok yes 96
but not much that I can do them so
you're just playing for a draw wow
really
it's very hard to not not not allow ok
now it's doing something else so let's
let's put this night up yeah objectively
I'm probably toast here hmm 96 check
this is one problem he just takes there
ok ok yeah I am I know this is a check
but what now put the see what is he
doing now threatening Queen g1 and night
h2 I night f2 so ok I'm happy to have
the night in the action that wasn't very
helpful for him so ok so isn't there
some kind of meteor looks it looks bad
check here cannot check that the don e 2
is bad quit before it's almost made but
not quite oh don't see a meteor may be
here for 492 I don't say I didn't see a
direct made which is probably
embarrassing
this is a mate oh no it's not i asked no
es kreeya's came to be fired
unbelievable yes the bloody came to be
five ah what a shame I didn't escape
them I was I was certainly a maid
somewhere ah no no no no no even that
position isn't so clear and 95 95 is
possible and I'm losing on time what
okay hey we went on time you can play
any nonsense move now that's the problem
can even blunder the Queen
hmmm of everything hahaha and the
automatically says thank you ah ah what
a game okay so so what okay so there are
many questions um let's see so long so
many people so many questions that's
very difficult there was a question
there's a question here about diet too
many too many questions guys yeah I've
seen I've seen that Simon Williams has
started his own commentary channel
that's fun yeah we might do a do look do
a commentary why not okay so let's get
this game going to 2k to Q key or
something and from Iceland probably an
Enzo yeah I did did hear that Cara wanna
is switching Federation's to the US yeah
that will make a pretty strong American
team but yeah I think I think it will be
probably interesting for them for them
chess olympiad next year mostly yeah
they have 3 m3 very strong Boston and a
couple of very promising juniors yeah
the US getting all those strong players
zone is so ever bad news for the for the
young promising players that they have
would be difficult now for them to get
on the team yeah maybe I had a header
header made then this in this in this
last game it's very very much likely
okay I'm trying for media as well
Queenie for Queen age seven mate crude
but I hope effective so any other
questions yeah in fact too many I wonder
ever should play g4 in this position is
an idea G for his night is really bad
there maybe rook g 1 and g for it funny
where g 4 immediately was awesome was
possible yeah that's true someone says
that individual players don't guarantee
em don't guarantee em a team victory as
we've seen with the result of the
Russian team over the years this is
really am a strange strange thing that
the Russian team is not getting anywhere
in the team events and what are here
it's not I mean what are here what I
read and some interviews and so on it's
not that they have for many personal
personal issues let's say sometimes you
just feel okay they are kind of don't
they don't like each other or something
no but it doesn't seem to be the case
here yeah someone says space and the
bishop pair I have to win this game
that's true this is just a very good
position unless I'm overlooking stuff
which is very much possible one point
that is tricky here is the f3 knight
which is really a bit of a soft spot
then yeah yeah yeah it rise he tries to
do something and of course he can check
on d5
I can take their ha tricky okay i can't
i can't take here first and thats that
cannot be bad and now night text if I
this I did not see that he can take on
e5 or that this is I mean I did see that
he can take but not that it is very
effective so take here takes g4 hmm
that's not good news I can take g7 but
that doesn't lead anywhere Kevin ok I'm
going to take them
gem-knight XG for now I don't really
have a great move here it's quite
remarkable I have a have have a pretty
good position for the pawn but it's not
a win okay so there's a question the
best way to learn sufficient theory to
play the limbs rainbow Union yeah well
okay this is a book coming that I'm that
I wrote which is a good good start
definitely it I think it will be
released in june I really hope the
publisher is kind of not doing anything
it seems I don't know what they're doing
actually I have submitted the book month
ago and not much is happening now it's
really a bit a bit strange um and well
the NIMS oh and bogo are both very
they're kind of their aid ideas based
openings not so much based on on forced
lines so it's not a bad idea to just
look through games bye bye good players
who regularly play the opening the NIMS
Oh is pretty easy in that regard it's
played very often and it's a very
versatile opening with many possible sub
variations and the bogo has experts as
well for example it's played a lot by
Russian Grand Master vichu golf yeah so
many em many source is possible okay he
wants to play nitey for doing the
sidestep that I'm not right in this in
this Fork
okay so it's giving something back and I
tries to give something back okay I'm
putting the rukon g one that seems to be
okay anyway I have some compensation I'm
not sure if it's enough for anything but
it is some compensation mm-hmm f5 and h6
doesn't seem to work group which is six
maybe ja he defended well I really had a
rotten position but Knight takes d5 that
was really strong surprisingly strong
okay I can take their two times now of
course my light squares are really
really bad now but I still think I
should do it as should do that Bishop
takes h6 is the point okay so what is he
doing Bishop age 694 check or what maybe
Queen takes rook f2 Wow
that's a nice piece of calculation there
by my opponent mmm takes have to i told
kim then don't have to i'd ever move
their kinky one maybe that's not going
to work great great nighty form then h
was hanging i really don't have a move
in this position that sucks it really
sucks this looks very passive I don't
see a move Wow
so his for up for nighty form again I
can take on age six though and still
what is he doing that okay let's let's
take them I can check on you for of
course you can still check there because
he has protected the square ok anyway I
had to have to play and move them yep
and here we go what is he doing now
that's at least a bit confusing it takes
the bishop i can take take the night ok
Wow ok that's a funny pin now it's night
is also pinned
dodging bullets iam really yeah winning
now I think wow that was probably
probably lost and now is nice for
failing on time but it's a winning King
at porn and game whoo okay so who's game
do i recommend wants to study the NIMS
oh um ja nims Oh difficult difficult
many many good players play the names oh
and um it is um as mentioned a very
versatile versatile opening many many
possibilities um yeah who's playing the
names Oh with the white um it depends on
what line um you choose of course if you
play the classical with Quincy to for
example there's a couple of a couple of
them good players to do that um dreher
for example is a player always recommend
to study them okay independiente that's
a very high rated player let's see if I
got a name in there nope there were
let's see ya even so Koloff is a is a
player to also look look at with the
white side of the dems oh he's a huge
expert on them on the Rubenstein III
Rubenstein variation okay so let's see
what we get here independiente he has
castle door they always hoped for h3 so
that I can unleash this this business
with g5 maybe I shouldn't have played
age 60 early
okay so I'm just going to cancel here
normal moves ah ok I think that playing
94 he is not leading to much a second
play rookie 8-bit should be six there's
a question do i watch Game of Thrones no
because too many too many too many
people I don't I cannot keep track but I
totally understand that people like it
it looks very very like very well
produced and like you it looks it looks
like a good stuff but impossible for me
to follow um there was another question
would I recommend judgment and planning
in chess by over hmm i'm not sure i
think i may be read that book i looked
at it like ages ago but I mean this is
it has to be quite naturally more than
35 years old as whoever died and i think
1980 and i'm not quite sure that this is
still kind of up to date and really a
lot has happened in chess and 30 years
for example i really don't think that
there's much using and stuffed by names
of each or something that's really too
old okay i'm trying to get this traded
their never liked it if there are too
many pieces daniel my king 9h five
trying to oh is some he's totally
agreeing to all those traits that i
think is surprising that must be must be
totally fine for me here with this good
centralization any Knight to f5 i can
simply take Wow f3 that's surprising
my dog's clear his dark squares look
really tricky coming with Quincy five my
thoughts on the bangko gambit is it any
good hmm i'm not sure i'm really not
sure the bangko is a tricky opening the
12 a 49 is some is putting this banker
under under quite some pressure but
recently it has been played by a natalia
paga nina very successfully in the world
women championships and and she played
it again zazou which i'm probably
totally killing in terms of
pronunciation and she didn't get any way
I had a Chinese player so that's
interesting she is usually quite well
prepared so this means something I have
a nice position Y M yeah the only Queen
85 is the point probably in the bank or
gambit but yeah I really cannot tell you
the the current state of things so he
played Bishop b3 what am I going to do I
mean I can just take and play like g6
and I'm fine but do I have something
better I can take and check him right is
this any good checking him
check King age 21 looks kind of tricky
let's do that let's do that and now is
in this awkward pin yeah i don't really
i bet i don't see anything great here
maybe queen bee hive or something okay i
want to make sure that the night is not
okay i was thinking that this might be
okay here like something to have one
okay i can go g5 now g5 night f5 not
sure it helps what is his idea actually
Group D to trading stuff maybe
Merck him know my opponents hanging I
didn't really appreciate that very much
okay not sure that was so great okay I'm
keeping control over the D file but it's
not so clear what my plan is yeah hmm
queen bee eight or something going for
efore check now it's probably equal this
kind of thing on is my default really
that important not sure oh now that no
I'm no I'm in great shape this is a
great end game let's see i'm not sure if
i can win but it's definitely nice for
black let's see how to do that maybe i
should have played rock each one for
each fire
ESG three maybe g3 Andrew h2 or
something maybe so let's see do I have
to play this or rookie 144 it's also
interesting let's do that and for if or
check so let's go a form that looks
excellent for black so III or not I can
also check him here let's check him King
now I have III and then take on g2
i whooped III is this the point I don't
know yeah what am i doing now I might I
can go King c4 but I don't know if I'm
winning then and the time is the problem
i only have 44 seconds i'm not sure if i
have a win now i think i should take the
draw him because of the time yeah it's a
bit a bit of a shame because it was such
a nice position but ok so let me have a
look at some of the possible questions
to answer um that's a question what do I
think of lines and symmetrical English
wear black plays a quick d5 like c4 c5
neither 306 Nazi to d5 how can you try
to challenge this kind of setup as white
I don't want to give black amarok see
bind position yeah that's not so easy
it's not so easy I think one ideas to
play with with III or reform after the
capture the best line for white against
the caro-kann yeah the best line
providing and circle come this would be
the advanced variation I guess the
advances currently the the main line and
there's a new book out by alexey dre f
not sure what it is called like beating
the calc on some of those some of those
typical things win against the caracal I
don't know we don't know the title but
he's got the advanced variation the
short variation um and it's pretty
pretty good I think um another
interesting line against the caro-kann
if you want something offbeat is the
fantasy variation with three f3 it tends
to be a surprise for the black players
ok yeah and the English if black is
going for d5 it's not so easy in this
particular line c4 c5 neither 3969 3g5 I
think CD 595 white can search for an
advantage with d 4 e 4 or III one of
those I wouldn't play g3 down and then
then black really gets in
reverse maroc see and this is really not
not any good I think for wide so i got a
new game there I'm what should I play
let's play the Sicilian someone
mentioned okay the dragon which I don't
get okay someone is yeah you know
someone is playing the Smith Mora and
I'm going to take it and how can you
check out this okay I don't want
something fancy I just want to play
normal stuff someone thought what in in
this book my mark s ammonia esselman
writes that this d65 setup is the for
him it's the kind of the ruler pass of
the of the of the Smith Maura so it's
the kind of super classical way to do it
for black so I'm going to go into go for
that what is happening here this guy 23
he allows me to put this nylon default
cannot be bad what is this in the first
place I can move the night now or I
wants to play Bishop e3 M that is what
he wants to do maybe rook c8 okay what
is this okay
can put Bishop to g5 right and then here
so it has a very clear goal in this game
he wants to play a bullet game okay I
really don't understand anything him um
what happens here hmm besides the fact
that probably there is some kind of
tactic that I don't see what I just
can't go back mm do you think the dragon
is only for crazy people a bit a bit the
the dragon is a specialist opening for
black players I mean it's definitely
interesting without any doubt but it's
also a very yeah it's a very demanding
opening not something that you can just
play and be happy with that you really
have to study it okay I don't like to
take with the porn but if I take with
the bishop it could have taken on c8 it
probably would have been compensation
but hmm not not great I still don't
really see his compensation which is
probably simply not existent this is why
I don't see it but you never know yeah
someone is getting back to this my
suggestion of playing D for the end the
symmetrical English line it done it it
does some it can transpose sometimes to
the group at it does not necessarily do
is do so yeah now he's taking time yeah
after blitzing out everything I don't
really know why you're just a pawn down
buddy that's the nature of this opening
yeah I cannot really the final zoosk one
is the name I'm sorry this is very
difficult to read it's in a green color
he's a mentioning a line down in the
English yeah okay it's difficult to read
out of all of it but just for for you
yeah this is an interesting line that i
also have played as wide yeah I know it
now it takes takes and takes two minutes
and exchanges his best piece that's
funny our bishop f7 is the point I
didn't really see that I didn't see that
you whoa whoa whoa whoa um yeah Bishop f
Selma Bishop f7 uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
what a stupid blunder and I don't really
have anything down stupid
yeah played that far too quickly totally
loves me into that what is the best way
to try to defend this is really its
relief that really sucks that I had that
I now have this kind of thing here dude
I cannot I cannot give me that because
of this pinned pin Brooke the only thing
that helps me a little bit yes my is
that is that the night is some is that
is a tricky piece ah I can just stick
with the porn of course it would have
been much better okay mr. Lester has to
win this position of course it's just
just an exchange but as long as you are
Knights your Knights you don't resign as
Larry Christians and coined famously
yeah I am it's really that's really the
case nights are tricky pieces so maybe
I'm entering here not doing a good job
covering f5 for example
and at the moment he doesn't have a very
clear idea how to win at least it
doesn't seem like it and fortunately I
also don't have anything great I can
just hope for for the best so maybe
attack the porn so that you cannot
easily play the rook to g3 yep still
cannot move the rook
you should probably play rook c1 or
something like that trying to I Roxy one
blunders the exchange chair 92 it's not
really leading to much okay I'm not sure
this is a good idea it could be just a
weakness but yeah a Troy goes to screen
up that's not great probably not a great
idea yeah I shouldn't have played h5
that was a bad idea he simply has no
idea this position is just shuffling
around and I'm probably giving him ideas
in some some way if you want okay so
let's do this this was the initial idea
okay so let's check this rook I know yes
rook c6 that's bad yeah I shouldn't have
allowed that airs was actually I've just
just stay put he may be wouldn't have
heaven slightest idea to win this with
an exchange up you never know but I just
weakened myself now I was bad defense i
should have just just stayed put can
check me there
okay well that was terrible that was a
really really bad game they're what okay
yeah the f7 tactic he took took and took
ages for that move and when he played it
I really didn't look okay so let's go
efore yeah for a change of pace against
Eddington here from Canada I could have
actually played the Kings gambit because
I have a great score with that maybe
maybe I can get some other gambit in
like here let's do the oven so that
could be fun I really don't know whether
that opening well but it could be fun
let's do this okay place the same line
that I play this Bishop e7 move adding
says recording video um yeah if you move
you're just told them that is live on
twitch him okay okay so he returned the
pawn it's playing the same boring line
that I play it's it's not a bad line
it's just not so a not so exciting I
also returned upon him any when I play
this and yeah I'm happy with this kind
of position for black it's nothing
brilliant but it's certainly ok so I'm
going to go back now and hope that the
white extra pawn in the center will will
be helpful
yeah this is the thing that white is
hoping for that the white epon is some
help helpful yeah someone writes
shouldn't you know the ovens from the
black side yeah I know it a bit but it's
um it's um something that um I know I
know this line a [ __ ] because it's my
line but I don't really don't really
know every possible deviation ok so
maybe Bishop g5 yeah just developing
someone someone requests I should play
especially boring openings someone says
you can see this nearly every day on my
channel that's not true actually I am I
really don't play them the exchange
lines that often anymore I've played a
bit of the exchange Slav and exchange
Kings Indian and so on but it's
relatively rare nowadays
yeah he's taking his sweet time him so
going to cover lady for black is okay
yeah I think he has he doesn't have any
bad PCM looks kind of solid I cannot go
e 5 which is a bit of a shame Bishop
there on g6 is making things a bit
problematic I wonder if not a choice
actually possible always rookie to
remove them now can I can I cannot be
good for black really i'd really love to
get this bishop here on g6 the bishop on
g6 is problematic
for me I mean this is on the diagonal of
the Queen yet see to g6 I have to get
rid of this oops i did not see that one
coming I had a bad feeling about all
this like that could be something but I
didn't see that move so 94 94 I have to
take anyway no use and spending time
there that's bad that I did not see that
coming so Bishop e7 Queenie seven hmm
bad news
not good yeah I guess I'm taking them
and I'm porn down there i am now that
happens when i play gambit openings I'm
upon down and i really ask myself what
exactly am i having for the pawn and I
have nothing the big problem is really
that he gets the bishop to f6 thats it's
really really annoying and rook e8 how
do i get the eight it's difficult to
even get some play really difficult yeah
them they exchanged variations like
exchange Slav exchange Kings Indian
there are not not bad at all in bullet
chess because they can be played quickly
if you if you know it and it's um it's a
good weapon if you have to if you want
to play many move some in a short period
of time I'm playing this badly and now
we can play before he didn't he didn't
play that why don't know why okay
I don't think he made the best out of
his chance Sam best off his chances um
jinx I'm still not in a good shape but
it looks better my piece coordination is
still still sucks but I not really sure
why he returned the pawn it wasn't
really necessary I think he could have
had the same position basically with
equal material quite an annoying queen
position maybe I should put play g3 and
just kick this kick the Queen out ok
let's do this
okay so can I if I let's say Teague and
play Queenie forces something taking see
for him or Queenie for immediately let's
play this first I have to do this anyway
protecting stuff okay now maybe rook be
70 96 then hmm my porn is hanging I
cannot play Queen 82 unfortunately over
here and I T Stick 96 it's still good
for him
there was a bit of a really bad game him
Luke c6 maybe I get that in okay then
that's equal now he really spoiled it to
an equal position but the time is 10
seconds up oops is seven maybe maybe I
get this in no not Queen g5 please yeah
it's it's a row of course
okay well there was a really bad game I
really played it played it played badly
it's not it's not my forte this kind of
positions but I overlooked them this
this tactic on your form so let's do one
one more game or two more games we
started really late down I don't really
know how late it was but quite a bit
late due to them technical problems at
the beginning I actually dropped below
2400 I have to fix that I really have
kept this 2400 plus for quite a bit oh
that's tricky now SWAT italic that's a
really strong player so let's see what's
going on it's really good so let's see
I'm playing the Kings Indian which is
not the opening that he has a bad score
against he really scores well against it
so let's see let's see what italic is
doing here in the classical is going for
this okay so he placed them the courts
no variation okay I'm playing this
gung-ho counter-attack rook f6 rook f6
to h6 this is a very young very cheeky
way to play in some way but ok let's see
you play g4 interesting huh ok I think I
probably have to take ok and night up to
f4 I guess and that cannot be bad really
or no that'sthat's wrong it might be bad
but it's probably it's probably the only
way to to play this position I really
don't see how else interesting so is up
form night yeah okay I don't already
cannot care about 95 year I'm going for
night h5 wow really that I find quite
surprising even g4 is a move now 27 for
Queen h3 how is he how is he pravasi
answering that actually be sure she
warned or something it still looks
dangerous let's try that rook g1 is a
funny way to get checkmated through cage
too yeah that's that's just made yeah
that was a lucky one but it happens it
happens yeah yeah I don't know I really
have a hard time to to UM to assess this
position maybe I'm in bad shape I don't
know the queen is coming to age three
and nine h5 g3 this is also an idea
that's the problem in the Kings Indiana
you can play all kinds of nonsense and
sometimes you just check mate the guy ok
let's do do one more ok let's go kings
in yet again yeah otter lake is really a
great player so I have lost many many
games against him buddy played really
great so so let's do something else here
against mr. Boris
getting a Ben Oni kind of structure yeah
the sameish Kings in yen yeah I've
played this a bit on the white side so
it's not that I don't know anything with
wider played age 3 in this kind of
situation I think back then h3 sorry h3
here I think yeah mmmm it's so long ago
it isn't even real
yeah that that little meeting trick
around 21 points let's often the weird
thing about chess some cheap trick gives
you many points and sometimes you play
an interesting good game and then I know
you lose some silly game on time you get
nothing okay it seems that he ok this is
also possible first trading everything
but I usually didn't didn't go for those
traits it's super tactical now h4 is the
point of blacks play to get them get the
night away and then maybe Tiki form
Black has some huge pressure on the sand
island in fact i was even pretty quick
now yeah what is he doing now like if
five maybe i don't know it raw it's a
bit of a problem another trick that
sometimes isn't the position is
something that if I can somehow take the
bishop on you three that Bishop deform
to to win material so that this is some
happening sometimes ok I think I have to
take probably I don't think I have
something else an important point is
that I'm checking the d5 pawn so if he
goes I don't know what exercise exactly
yeah like this actually 95 I can play or
not I can also play h4 h4 first hmm well
Bishop d4 might be something it's a 95
Bishop deform
maybe a may be possible if I go H form
Bishop before i can actually take on d5
with the rook that's pretty good
actually so let's do that Bishop d 495
sorry bishop before rook t5 that's
pretty good I think unless unless it's
not unless it's not wait Bishop b4 b5
9525 or does he have something crazy
Queen f4 or something I don't know let's
see what he's doing he probably has to
do that no he's just moves the Queen ok
so I cannot move the night because then
f7 is collapsing hmm I can take g5 with
the rook
Wow Kings Indiana and wacky stuff 9525
and I'm double-checking c5 and the night
on g3
the bishop is hanging with shaken when
Bishop deform I have night h5 I think
yes check on b8 this might be the
problem and that he has this check their
own beard okay I can still take them
takes on g3 Bishop f6 Bishop see sex is
an interesting line and i have i still
have night h5 somehow or other night
moves is there some decent night move I
don't know the ship's six now what is he
doing after Bishop c6 actually let's do
that let's do that
little intermediate mate in the works
look f2 I can take AG three and then
winning so this is not going to work
funny tricky tricky tricky I don't
really know what he's doing now queen of
three or something I have Queen D for
check
there also is a possibility to play g5
looks really crazy but I assess check on
be eight so that's not working yeah yeah
I can't just take I think hmm oh I
didn't see that move sorry for that hmm
I didn't see that one coming not sure
how bad it is so what am i doing queen
hmm do I have something else don't have
a check that's bad Queenie six looks
normal actually for Queenie walnuts oh
yes is check but that's not it's not
really a big problem night h5 is
blocking queen age for checks and
Queenie one is really a big issue that
should be okay also taking the bishop so
it cannot just play a no Queen g3 or
something
I already resigned I didn't see that
hira psyched I'm sitting there Oh what
is happening no I didn't get it okay I'm
going to go for one more game let's see
yeah that was a funny funny technical
skirmish so I'm going to go for one more
game the the rocky start really
warranted I didn't really see that you
assigned him but i think it is lost
there it really is lost again mr. italic
let's see what he's going to do he's
playing he's playing the Greenfeld i
think so i'm playing the bishop f online
yeah his [ __ ] playing but should be six
he's there he's a real theory guy there
should be six as nowadays that no he's
going for that okay interesting
I think you just play this one
I really I forgot I forgot my
preparation night you for here okay not
familiar with that this late 94 so let's
see I want to get rid of this strong
bishop down and I managed that's good
the bad thing is I'm moving my night all
over the place but I think it's worth to
get rid of this strong bishop yep
interesting what am i doing now just
going back or I can take give five maybe
I wonder about Queen d 4 is this a
stupid idea maybe not sure really but
okay let's play it simple i mean this
shouldn't be bad he is kind of his
famiiy and threatening on d5 here he has
to play Knight takes you three now I
think yeah this is almost the same thing
I was thinking about this this this is
just a little bit better for white I
know it's kind of kind of boring but
it's it's just a bit better for what so
will it see Bishop e2 or Bishop see form
yeah maybe Bishop c4 yeah I probably
probably should have played something a
little bit more entertaining
so hmm I'm a bit surprised that he
traded this why did he give me night
Bishopville night that's a bit strange
okay
I mean it's it's not that he's in
serious trouble but I wonder what the
point is to give me an end game where if
anybody is better it's wired
still very Jewish of course
so let's see where do I put it I cannot
really enter easily with the King may be
here night on the six is blocking
blocking things it's equal ish it's just
equal
hmm if five is surprising
trying to enter now doctor really
understand what he's doing him
so just playing for loss here I mean
maybe I'm just totally not understanding
things but I'm getting there poor now I
could have played Bishop c4 here which
was interesting weird okay so Bishop
Bishop over 2g eight would be great okay
wants to go to to e6 so i guess a 3 a 3
before maybe or before immediately man
that some that's the tricky thing here
III before he's got 96 night x and form
yeah I don't know cannot calculate it to
the end
so my a porn is pretty pretty dangerous
so if 5 or i can i can play also be five
just try to promote be six be 500 tanks
be 60 is he stopping that I don't see
how it stops it let's do it how is he
stopping this stuff I don't see it
oh I totally miss counted them i
miscounted this nonsense no no he's just
one move too quick I I just had the
clearly better end game they totally
killed himself terrible that was just
terrible I can just not not be five and
I'm never losing this of course never
I'm just winning I think I mean not
never losing totally miscounted
yeah that's just lost I guess when I
came out calculate now with five seconds
I'm clear my quick enough him okay now
that was terrible already losing that is
quite a joke actually if I'm not doing
I'm not miss counting him yeah like am
sorry like here can just go 85 I mean I
can never lose with the a pond it's
impossible the question is I can
probably not win but I can never lose
actually and no b6 was not working v6
was not working here b6 I cannot cannot
really analyzing this is client I don't
really know it yeah yeah in this
position b6 he just goes King c5 and and
stops the whole business okay guys that
was a bit of a bit of a late start to
this broadcast but i think i made up for
it for going a little bit over time i
hope you enjoyed the whole show again
sorry for the for the late start and
yeah i'll be back next Monday with
another hour of chess explains okay
thanks guys bye